hey everybody happy Saturday I hope
everybody's doing all right out there
I didn't touch it you did that you
Pookie problems yes she comes in and
headbutts it when I'm not in here
so what yet Saturday so you went to
Sam's yesterday which is Sam's because
we're out of cat food and eggs they had
it to where I had it going through a
line all right and they were gonna
channel us through there I didn't really
like I didn't really like it so I just
kind of broke off a little bit one
supposed to do with that and then I ran
down there like a crazies and grab some
[ __ ] and took it back to the shopping
cart and then I happen to notice that
[ __ ] there was the last of the damn
almond milk I said [ __ ] it I jumped over
I went and grabbed because I'm the kind
of dude that if the plane crashes and
[ __ ] catches on fire I'm climbing over a
[ __ ] top that's nice to know
yeah climbing over a [ __ ] top may be
nice to know you're gonna just leave me
to burn to death what well you don't had
to hold on but you know they've got old
people up there or [ __ ] obese people
you don't need to slow in my survival I
invested too much [ __ ] and in [ __ ] my
own survival that's some slugs stand in
my way I'm a crawl right over the
[ __ ] top oh yeah they were keeping
every me like burn [ __ ] burn I'm out of
here
I'll [ __ ] deal with survivor's guilt
afterwards a Big Damn I can't believe I
can't believe I [ __ ] jumped over all
those people my god that's just terrible
alright what's for dinner yeah that's
pretty yeah [ __ ] sometimes pays off man
I know how it is
no English people is survived the damn
[ __ ] accidents in the [ __ ] you know
they all had survivor guilt because they
did that data same damn thing climbing
over a [ __ ] table people they were
trying to keep everybody six feet apart
so they were just like letting they
didn't want you to like wander off by
yourself he trusted well-known informant
you didn't really tell me cuz you said
that they did a lot of [ __ ] yeah that
they didn't have some stuff so you went
to all day yeah and all these was wide
open it was civilized it was
european-style
because you know that's a European
company it is yeah
so determinate they just let us in they
just let yeah and I liked all these a
lot better and it was actually if
stocked up pretty well I guess cuz
people didn't think about all these
which is weird because all these like
they they have some good like yet small
it's like yeah they got like good [ __ ]
in there though yeah you know one thing
I really like and they're they always
seem to have like you know a lot of
people like maybe complain because they
don't the same brands all the time
because they just kind of get whatever
um but every time I've been I've been
able to find they have these little
coffee drinks that are just like frat
they're like frappuccinos but not you
know they're not quite as big but
they're like the small ones and they're
like half the price you have like the
Starbucks one and I think they taste a
bit they were hitting Sam's Club hard Oh
Sam's has been crowded for like three
weeks [ __ ] yeah great as far as I know
this is the beginning of the damn month
too so that had a lot to do it so
everybody got money and I also stopped
off and got cat food and Rotel and two
cans of damn bacon spam that's right
spam stockpile so the first time I fed
her some bacon spam that was it sorry I
fried it I mean I I soaked it in egg
yolk yeah it's for a breakfast yeah it's
what's good for ya breakfast and I made
home fries with the whipped up man
hey [ __ ] dogs yes the neighbors never
really annoy the home fries and eggs and
spam yeah it was good and although like
I said I can't eat anything it was just
like the biscuits and gravy yesterday I
can't do any calorie stuff also what
yeah so I went to Walmart oh my god
yeah I went to Walmart to to get the cat
food like I said I don't know if you
know if you're gonna get affected it's
gonna be at Walmart
I'm sure like I said a nut and that's
like even before oh [ __ ] and Walmart was
just kind of chaos people just running
around there wasn't much distance and
you could tell you know yeah I sitting
here looking at this and looking at that
and trying to figure out what's the
which is the best survival food to get I
could see it you think they would have
figured that [ __ ] out by now it says
this has been going on for like weeks
and weeks come on people
dude didn't I mean it is Walmart some
[ __ ] they were getting I was kind of
like I said I don't even like going to
Walmart even when it's not a [ __ ] she
was getting a whole bunch of ramen and
I'm thinking there's no nutrition in
that yeah yeah in it well you can put
other [ __ ] in no you can put like
vegetables and meat and eggs and stuff
in there and I saw that damn Walmart
brand protein powders strawberry protein
with creatine oh god that [ __ ] was oh
yeah he did the sound effect that
everything when I took it so fast that
the vacuum made that noise oh that was
the air rushing into the spot where you
caused this tiny worm hole yeah yeah
yeah cool and then so yeah all these
actually I guess people weren't thinking
of all these because it's small yeah
they don't have all the things can
either by all that then you're probably
thinking oh man that [ __ ] there's
probably [ __ ] empty so if all these
look good chances are Trader Joe's which
is the same thing yes dating company
which actually I didn't know until I saw
it on a video yeah it was company man
right brought you did a video about all
day and he was talking to me yeah it's
the same company for some reason they
can't compete two different divisions of
the same company yeah it's like it's um
well like I said I think it's a German
company it's a German or Norwegian
German I think and like so they yeah
they have like a North Division and a
South Division yeah and like um I'm
pretty sure oh I can't remember which
one is in the US but yeah they they do
Trader Joe's yeah I got a bunch of pork
sausage so I can make some more country
gravy oh yeah I saw that one I've got
all this with ham steaks yeah we got ham
steak ahead yeah and and it was
reasonable yeah but yeah it's because I
couldn't I couldn't getting hamburger
it's alright I'll go back I'll go back
and try it again I mean like I said I
I'm not real super be sure like a really
good cook and it's like so I eat pretty
much anything yeah well I don't want to
say anything cuz who knows why you're
gonna pull out of here but just to like
prove that but I'll I'll eat most things
I don't like I only cook good food I'm
just kidding anyway um you wouldn't do
that to me no but yeah so um oh I wanted
to say I can't believe okay so we
recorded the Steven Seagal show last
night right and I was editing it earlier
and that's why I glanced over there and
was like oh [ __ ] cuz it was um I had it
like all put together like in filmora
and then I was exporting it and the
computer crashed in the middle of its
own and we didn't listen um I know I
saved the file so it'll just have to
like oh this dress is the Terminator
yeah you're it's pretty cute but you
know what I mean it's like so when I was
like editing it I was like oh my god I
can't believe cuz we talked about like a
bunch of fun like Steven Seagal stories
and stuff but I can't believe I totally
totally forgot to mention his music
career I totally did not even but and I
can't believe that I neglected yeah well
he's so of course we kind of have to
mention it he's a Renaissance man
yeah he's a man of all skills and well
the weird thing he has two albums out as
far as I can determine the first was
called songs from the crystal cave for
chrissake and that actually has like
some really genuinely like actual people
with actual talent like Stevie Wonder
and stuff so he was able to like finagle
famous people and the like working on
the record um the second one I think
like I listen to like snippets of it and
I'm just like okay um it's mostly just
the lyrics that are bad it's like you
know and it's like the second album
which I think he tried to do like a
delta blues type of thing and he's doing
the thing cuz you know when how we were
talking about on the show like how he
always like tries to talk like he's
changes his race by gender yeah so he
was like doing that kind of stuff just
in a really like like he'll say stuff it
is song like that you know like that
would be fat you know what I mean
vhat and Stefan he's like the whitest
dude and there's a song on the second
album and the title of it is and I am
NOT making this up the title of it is
alligator ass alligator ass yeah what
could that song possibly be about sweat
going down your butt correct and
Louisiana um
yeah walk around dirty with swamp ass so
like swamp ass yeah
I've never heard it called alligator ass
I be so bad you saw him in Louisiana he
might makeup yeah and the an honest way
dirty underwear in Louisiana that sounds
like something you know
well if you live in the south that you
kind of know about it whether you want
to or not sweaty but yeah um yeah and
like some and one of the songs I think
it's called strut and it actually has
the lyric and it's like I'm cringing
just thinking about saying it out loud
it actually has the lyric me want the
punani yeah he wrote that [ __ ] himself
he said that's that's a that's a say it
out loud and like I had I was like
because I saw like this on it I'm like
because the video is the [ __ ] on
YouTube and I'm like do I want to listen
to this thinks just [ __ ] 1930 or not
1930 Mississippi and [ __ ] and then I did
and I was like just made me feel icky
all over 1930s Mississippi Blues and
[ __ ] yeah he's full of [ __ ] who is
letting him get away with that don't let
him get away with that he had the money
so he you know put he was able to put
together I guess so but it's like I
can't believe either like didn't even
mention before I made money on that
album
probably I think he's got a hardcore
fanbase it'll just buy everything well
that's kind of like the guy dude that
did the Wallace to go yeah yeah he's
like that guy he's like I don't really
he's like I think he's kind of a douche
in his movies are bad but it's like he
likes him like ironically yeah you know
I mean in like in like a hippies are
fascinating man he's a fascinating man
oh yeah and I'll give him that
he's it like he's fascinating because
this terrible he's an American original
yeah yeah from Michigan yeah he is from
his head he's half Italian
he's half Irish and part Jewish okay but
yes yeah I'm very bright yeah
math as it is strong he's spiritual man
he didn't know anything about this 135
percent
I guess so it's like yeah but seriously
with the the show will be out if you're
a patron you'll get to see it on Monday
but like everyone else get to see it on
Tuesday and I think it came out pretty
funny like we did we weren't like super
super drunk I think I only had like one
drink so I was still like pretty lucid
but um you know he's like a fun topic so
we went
like no structure at all we just kind of
like wet here and there I've been
keeping up with things on on my YouTube
feed just to warn you people some people
are going [ __ ] crazy especially up
around New York in California
this whole [ __ ] pandemic they're
losing everything that they [ __ ] have
people and their family members are at
risks they're losing their businesses
their world is coming to an end a lot of
them and they're [ __ ] going crazy
yeah they're threatening to kill people
and calling other people and blaming
other people for their problems this
[ __ ] could go south and this all goes
back to you know Nostradamus has [ __ ]
called a lot of this so just as
subscribers to the show watch your six
[ __ ] just make sure you don't make
sure you're not around crazy people lay
low let this [ __ ] blow yeah but like
what if the crazy people are in your own
house and you can't get away I said the
early honester told the entire art it's
a shining I told the entire army that it
it is their responsibility to [ __ ]
cover their own asses they'd better be
ready just in case protect yourself and
your family keep an eye out for [ __ ]
lunatics some people are gonna [ __ ]
lose it and I told you guys I said you
need to watch that that documentary is
from The History Channel it's got to be
15 almost 20 years old now it's called
after Armageddon you can just look it up
and it talks about that says some people
aren't built for this [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] fly the [ __ ] out off the [ __ ]
handle a lot of people are all these
weird [ __ ] reuptake inhibitor [ __ ]
drugs and when the drugs run out or they
just think that they can't they've never
really experienced life in full color
and when something bad happens they
[ __ ] lose it so just keep make sure
it make sure make sure you be in safe
people it's all going to say you see
some more I'm so you know we're gonna
send more edition I'm sure most people
are not going to be
like putting themselves in lunatics yeah
well just getting people mentally ready
they're boarding up all the damn
storefronts in New York especially all
the high-end stuff they had Louis Louis
Vuitton just locked up tight as a tick
they [ __ ] hammered boards all around
it they're they're preparing for the
[ __ ] apocalypse I had one of you
remember like on the side Trek show that
we did the other day where I talked
about some like people having to plan
funerals like in the middle of pandemic
and like having to livestream them stuff
and I was like wow that's like really
weird I'm like something that I didn't
really think about and somebody
commented on the YouTube thing that them
that they're I think their father-in-law
or their former father-in-law had died
and they had to do they had to
livestream the funeral and he's like it
was kind of good though because it was
like a lot of people that could have
come there were like in other countries
and stuff like that they wanted to be
there and they couldn't be there
obviously um so it's kind of cool and I
was like I guess I didn't like I didn't
mean that it was weird like you know I
didn't want it like anybody to get
offended by that it's just weird because
I guess I always associated
live-streaming with likes like positive
stuff you know what I mean like oh well
livestream the wedding so people can't
so people that can't be there could be
there well I showed like a birthday
party or something like that so I could
see that but then I was like well yeah I
guess you'd have to do it for a funeral
too is you can't go yeah cuz nobody can
go right um and I and then I got kind of
curious it's like so I wonder if that
was like if like a like a thing even
before the pandemic started no you know
what I mean people can't go to church
they're doing their also live ya know
I'm nervous
well that yeah the people are doing that
before yeah but now you know that's well
then you have to but I was just saying
that people were live-streaming like
happy events before like I said like
weddings or parties or whatever and
concerts and stuff so I just wondered if
people were live-streaming funerals like
if that was becoming a trending thing
even before like the dynamic things
started no I hadn't heard of it before
but you know that doesn't mean that I
did because this pandemic yeah that that
doesn't mean that um it wasn't anything
that was going on I also wanted to say
something because what we were talking
about yesterday about male and female
writers and male and female directors
and stuff like that and somebody
commented that um how surprised they
were when they found out that The Hurt
Locker had been directed by a woman and
I was like that it's funny because after
we've recorded the show
that was like the first movie that I
thought of she and that was Kathryn
Bigelow and she directed a near dark
also which I said we really have to do a
retrospective on that that's like one of
the best vampire movies ever
um and then I was saying that I
remembered being really surprised I
couldn't think of it while we were
recording the show but I remembered
being really surprised when I found out
that a woman had directed the original
Pet Sematary and also American Psycho
yeah that was also a female director and
like that's something that you wouldn't
I wouldn't have known that like you know
in case I looked it up and like I said I
think I've recommended this movie on the
show before but another female director
movie and probably one of my favorite
horror movies is like the last 10 years
the invitation which is directed by uh
what's-her-name and Kusama Karyn Kusama
of whatever the name is she did
Jennifer's body also and that's like
really really good like a really really
tense movie was like a really great
ending and [ __ ] like that so I just want
to recommend that also uh google shudder
they just said it not only did they add
almost all of the Friday the 13th movie
it's like the first eight of them anyway
um and some other [ __ ] too they're
starting a new miniseries which is
called cursed films and I guess it's
gonna be five episodes they're putting
them up one at a time just like they did
with Creepshow so like they're gonna put
one up every week or whatever it looks
like it looks like they were putting
them up once like on Friday and they're
gonna talk about just five different
movies and like behind the scenes stuff
and like all the kind of you know movies
that were kind of like cursed or had
like all these like bad things happen
around them so like the first I watched
the first one last night they're only
half an hour and the first one last
night was about The Exorcist and so they
were like talking about kind of the PR
behind it where they were saying oh
people were passing out in the theaters
and like you know the devil is really in
the movie and all this other kind of
stuff he was already well yeah well the
woman on there said that said that was
like pretty much all PR um but you know
that's a smart thing to do they've been
doing that since like the 40s 50s maybe
earlier and I think they got church
people to go think made it made a damn
donation to damn Jerry Falwell get him
to get him to talk about it you know see
that when other Devils in the movie well
it would be it would be a smart thing to
do more thing for both of them to do
that you
falwell that was another like I said
that was essentially a Christian movie
yeah
and Jerry will fall Java fall well the
best plug he could give is to tell say
don't see it don't see it cuz it up the
Devils Devils in that movie and you know
and I'm sure if you if you don't donate
it to so I could Church you know he'd go
out there and say that for you yeah and
all of his parish would go check that oh
yeah cuz you know that's how he was kind
of a ho and maybe like take money to say
anything yeah you know but you know what
I mean so and another thing that I
didn't really think of and I didn't know
much about this because I knew some of
the [ __ ] like a bunch of the people that
you know died like that were on the crew
or like relatives of the actors and
stuff that died during the filming and
so that kind of got like a reputation of
having a curse or whatever but I didn't
know that after the movie came out
people were like [ __ ] on Linda Blair
like she was really possessed by the
devil like it wasn't just a movie how do
you remember that and it's like she had
to get like a bodyguard and stuff like
that because people are stupid as [ __ ]
she was cute [ __ ] though man hurt her
whole she was such an adorable little
girl and I do feel like even though the
Exorcist is like one of the best horror
movies ever made and she's [ __ ]
phenomenal in it but it's kind of sad
because it really does seem like it kind
of ruined her career I mean I'm not
saying that she would have I don't know
what her career would have been like if
she was only 12 like when that when she
did that movie but it's like I don't
really know because she ended up being
in like she was in Hell night which was
like a pretty good like a slasher but
then she ended up being like in all
those like cheesy like exploitation like
women in prison movies she was an
exorcist - for Christ she was older than
me by good ten years I think yeah well
like so now maybe not that much maybe
not that much just I remember you know
when Exorcist was kind of knew I was
seeing pictures of her it was like man
you know cuz I was a little kid I was
probably both said yeah what did that
come out 7373
okay so I was actually more like four
yeah but I remember seeing it I guess I
had been out for a few years I'm about
six seven eight eight and I just thought
she was just knockout she was yes she
was like a really cute girl and actually
when she got older she was like she has
she said my god look this good and
there's like there's
more than one movie outside my movie she
was writing there's 12 in the movie I
think she was 12 when she shot that
alright cuz that yeah I always thought
of her as Oliver woman even you know she
was older than a 4 years older than me I
was 7 I think when I first noticed her
yeah and I that movie came I was only
one I only came out make stars come
around in my head as a little boy yeah
my ex-husband had a thing for her - yes
we even had like a big poster of her
from [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that movie
that she wasn't not born innocent that
was the one with the plunger but um one
of the prison ones where she was like I
get some kind of cat seed or something
like that and we always had like a
poster of like a framed poster burn our
house like for a long time ago because
my exercise needs to be inter but um
yeah so so I'm not sure what other
movies they're gonna do like so the
extras is the first one and then like
next Friday I know they're gonna do
poltergeist because there was some you
know there was all kind of [ __ ] like cuz
you know [ __ ] Carroll and I the older
sister got shot by her boyfriend you
know that there was the whole thing
about the the real corpses and the pull
holy [ __ ] like that so I think they're
gonna talk about that but I don't know
what the other three are gonna be but
it's like it seems like a good series
and it's like a cool idea um they're
pretty short but you know like I said
we'll see how that goes
also we just started watching and some I
think somebody recommended like one of
our listeners or somebody recommended us
to watch the series on Netflix Kingdom
the Korean Zombie see yeah we only mean
this two seasons so it's like we only
watched the first episode of the first
season 2 episodes and then I watched
like part of the second but I fell
asleep because I was exhausted
OOP so we probably have to at least back
it up - si Clarion Walking Dead but it's
in the medieval better in the medieval
era yeah and so so thanks to ever like
um you know recommended that because
Matt's Trippi okay there we go so um
yeah so it's pretty cool so we'll
probably be watching that for the next I
mean we got to watch some new movies do
you like to to do for next week's
matinee but um we might review that if
we finish it in time I don't know if we
well cuz like I said we're still only
like two episodes into the first season
and that's two seasons yeah anything
else I don't think so I think probably
about I mentioned crazy people state
your steer clear
just watch watch it advice any anytime
watch how it goes
I mean I'm well aware of how this [ __ ]
goes have been studying it for a long
time but can well I was involved in
Katrina and this is now global you're
gonna see some weird [ __ ] in the next
couple weeks people all right so just
mentally get yourself ready you're gonna
see some people [ __ ] crack you're
gonna see famous people going crazy
you're gonna see people on the news
saying crazy [ __ ] you're gonna see
things like cops getting sick and dying
especially up in that New York area
that's where it's really that's where
it's really gonna hit them work you're
gonna see a lot of bad behavior and
people that you believed in they're
gonna get defrocked by this you'll see
I'm not I don't have any predictions
about who I'm just saying a lot of
people lose it under [ __ ] pressure
and stress stress and you really you
know it becomes unveiled of who's cut
out for it who is it some people can't
handle [ __ ] death you know I mean or
you're even pain and suffering I
remember remember there was something
you know takes me back to [ __ ] basic
training where me and all the guys that
made it we'd be on these long runs and
[ __ ] doing all this endurance tests
for [ __ ] weeks and weeks we're waking
up is war time so they were [ __ ]
pushing this real hard wake up in the
morning half of us had nosebleeds from
iron deficiency their foot putting us on
KP and [ __ ] and as you start seeing the
week fall behind and be eliminated out
of the process there's some kind of
vampiric quality in you where you they
get weaker and you get stronger there's
this weird feeling about in times of
harsh and in real hard time sometimes
you get a feeling of elation when you
see others go down and fail you'll see
what I'm talking about it's weird it's
weird it's as nature divides the strong
from the weak the strong become
empowered at seeing the weak fail and
die off or be eliminated it's weird any
part of an animal parts part of that
damn and it's probably just you
that was all of us is all of us probably
yeah everybody everybody that made it
through all that [ __ ] that's where you
know you know I'm seeing this certain
men bond under this kind of that's where
all that bonding took place yeah you'll
see veterans in the down comment section
here they go yeah I remember that's like
and that's what divides us from them
that's that kind of mentality you know
yeah I'll just I'll just always remember
that you're gonna climb over my burn
I'll climb right over you to get out of
it I'm gonna hold on you been all over
like a belt loop you know I got your
back JT now you know sure all right so
that'll do it for our Saturday show hope
you guys are staying all right out there
keep your [ __ ] together you know we're
all going through this in one thing
it'll be all right that's what they say
eventually that's what they say
eventually it all works out well
eventually in one way or another yeah
like I said there's nothing you do about
it these things kind of like wait works
out and it works out one way or another
it works out one way and another it
works out and you'll see works out one
way for some people works out another
way for some other for you well yeah
it's all on the right side that's kind
of true of any city that's what I'm
saying really yes all right so uh you
guys stay safe and healthy out there and
we will talk to you again two more